Vous savez, ces derniers jours,
en préparant mon intervention,
je suis devenue de plus en plus nerveuse
sur ce que j'allais dire, et de me retrouver sur la même scène
que tous ces gens fascinants.
Être sur la même scène qu'Al Gore, la première personne pour qui j'ai voté.
Et --
(Rires)
et ma nervosité augmentait,
je ne savais pas que Chris était assis sur scène,
c'est encore plus stressant.
Puis j'ai commencé à penser à ma famille.
J'ai commencé à penser à mon père et à mon grand-père
et mon arrière grand-père,
et j'ai compris
que j'avais tous ces Ted
du même sang que moi --
(Rires)
-- que je devais --
penser que j'étais dans mon élément.
Donc -- qui suis-je ?
Chris a dit que j'avais monté une société avec mon mari.
Nous employons environ 125 personnes dans le monde.
Si vous avez lu le livre,
vous avez vu cela,
qui m'a horrifiée.
(Rires)
Et comme je voulais vous impressionner tous avec des diapos,
puisque j'ai vu les excellentes présentations d'hier avec des graphiques,
j'ai fait un graphique qui bouge,
et je parle de ce qui me compose.
(Rires)
Donc, à côté de ce truc monstrueux,
voilà ma diapo scientifique. Là, ce sont des maths,
et là c'est de la science, c'est de la génétique.
Là c'est ma grand-mère, c'est d'elle que je tiens ma bouche.
(Rires)
Donc,
je suis une blogueuse, ce qui veut probablement dire
des choses différentes pour beaucoup d'entre vous.
Vous avez peut-être entendu parler du verrou Kryptonite
et du scandale que ça a fait, quand un blogueur a dit comment casser,
ou forcer, un verrou Kryptonite à l'aide d'un stylo bille,
et ça a fait tache d'huile. Kryptonite a dû corriger le verrou,
ils ont dû régler le problème
pour éviter d'inquiéter trop de consommateurs.
Vous avez peut-être entendu parler du Rathergate,
qui a découlé du fait
que des blogueurs ont compris que le "th"
dans "111th"
n'a pas été tapé sur une vieille machine mais sur Word.
Donc, les blogueurs ont révélé cela,
ou ont travaillé dur pour le faire.
Vous savez, les blogs sont effrayants. Voici ce qu'on y voit.
En voyant cela, on a forcément peur --
en étant vulgaire -- on fait dans son froc,
parce que ça n'a pas l'air rassurant.
Mais certains blogs
changent notre manière de lire les infos et de consommer les médias,
et ce sont d'excellents exemples. Ces gens touchent des milliers,
voire des millions de lecteurs,
c'est d'une importance capitale.
Pendant l'ouragan,
MNSBC a mis des posts sur l'ouragan sur son blog,
en le mettant souvent à jour. Cela a été rendu possible
à cause du caractère facile des outils de blog.
J'ai aussi un ami,
qui a un blog sur le numérique --
sur un PDR, un enregistreur personnel.
Il gagne assez d'argent, rien qu'en diffusant des pubs,
pour faire vivre sa famille dans l'Oregon.
Il ne fait plus que ça maintenant, et c'est quelque chose
que les blogs ont rendu possible.
Autre exemple : Interplast.
C'est une organisation formidable
de gens et de docteurs qui vont dans les pays en développement
pour offrir de la chirurgie réparatrice à ceux qui en ont besoin.
Des enfants avec un bec de lièvre en bénéficient,
et ils racontent leur histoire. C'est merveilleux.
Je ne suis pas si généreuse.
(Rires)
Je parle de moi. C'est ce que je suis : une blogueuse.
J'ai toujours décidé que j'allais être une experte en une seule chose,
et je suis experte sur cette personne,
donc j'écris sur elle.
Et --
pour résumer l'histoire de mon blog : il a commencé en 2001. J'avais 23 ans.
Mon travail ne me plaisait pas,
parce que j'étais designer,
mais ça ne me stimulait pas.
J'avais fait des études de lettres à la fac. Elles ne me servaient pas,
mais l'écriture me manquait. Donc, j'ai commencé à tenir un blog
et à inventer des choses comme ces petites histoires.
Ceci est une illustration sur mon expérience en colo quand j'avais 11 ans,
et comment je suis allée à une colo YMCA -- chrétienne --
et en fait à la fin, j'avais
fait en sorte que mes amis me détestent tellement
que je me suis cachée dans une couchette. Ils ne pouvaient pas me trouver.
Ils ont commencé à faire des recherches, et j'ai entendu des gens dire
qu'ils auraient aimé que je me sois suicidée,
que j'aie sauté de Bible Peak.
Donc -- vous pouvez rire, ça va.
C'est ce qui m'a faite -- c'est moi.
C'est ce qui m'est arrivé.
Quand j'ai commencé mon blog j'avais vraiment cet unique objectif,
je voulais -- j'avais compris, je disais que
je ne serais jamais célèbre
mondialement
mais que je pourrais être célèbre sur Internet.
Je me suis fixé un objectif. Je me suis dit que j'allais gagner un prix,
parce que je n'avais jamais gagné de prix.
J'ai dit, je vais gagner ce prix --
le prix du blog "South by Southwest".
Et j'ai gagné. J'ai atteint des gens,
j'avais des dizaines de milliers de lecteurs chaque jour sur ma vie.
Puis j'ai écrit un post sur un banjo.
J'ai écrit un post
sur le fait de vouloir acheter un banjo --
un banjo à 300 dollars, ce qui est beaucoup.
Je ne joue pas de musique,
je n'y connais rien.
J'aime la musique, et j'aime les banjos,
je crois que j'ai entendu Steve Martin en jouer.
Je me suis dit, je peux le faire. Et j'ai dit --
j'ai dit à mon mari "Ben, je peux acheter un banjo ?" Et lui "Non".
Et mon mari --
voici mon mari, qui est très sexy --
il a gagné un prix parce qu'il est sexy --
(Rires)
-- il m'a -- il m'a dit
"Tu ne peux pas acheter un banjo, c'est --
tu es comme ton père, qui achète -- qui collectionne les instruments."
Alors j'ai écrit un post
sur le fait que j'étais en colère contre lui,
c'était vraiment un tyran, il ne me laissait pas acheter ce banjo.
Ceux qui me connaissaient ont compris ma plaisanterie.
C'est Mena, c'est comme ça que je plaisante avec les gens.
Parce que la plaisanterie, c'est qu'il n'est pas un tyran :
il est tellement aimant et tellement adorable
qu'il me laisse le travestir
et mettre des photos de lui sur mon blog. Et --
(Rires)
-- et s'il savait que je suis en train de montrer ça,
je l'ai mis aujourd'hui, il me tuerait.
Mais en fait, j'ai écrit cela, mes amis l'ont lu,
et ils se sont dit, oh, cette Mena, elle a écrit un post
sur le fait de vouloir une bêtise et elle fait l'idiote.
Mais j'ai reçu des e-mails de gens qui disaient:
"Mon Dieu, ton mari est un vrai connard.
Combien d'argent il dépense en bière chaque année?
Tu pourrais prendre cet argent et acheter ton banjo.
Pourquoi tu n'ouvres pas un compte séparé?"
Je suis avec lui depuis que j'ai 17 ans. Nous n'avons jamais eu de compte séparé.
Ils disaient "Prends un compte séparé --
dépense ton argent, dépense son argent. C'est tout."
Des gens m'ont dit "Quitte-le".
Et --
je me disais, mais qui sont ces gens,
et pourquoi lisent-ils cela?
Et j'ai compris : je ne veux pas toucher ces gens.
Je ne veux pas écrire pour ce grand public.
J'ai donc commencé à tuer mon blog à petit feu.
C'était, je ne veux plus écrire cela,
et à petit feu, à tout petit feu --
Je racontais des histoires personnelles de temps en temps.
J'en ai écrit une, et j'en parle à cause d'Einstein aujourd'hui.
Je vais avoir les larmes aux yeux, parce que c'était mon premier oiseau,
et il est mort il y a deux ans.
J'ai décidé de casser le "Je n'écris pas vraiment sur ma vie publique"
parce que je voulais lui offrir un petit mémorial.
Mais enfin.
Ce sont ces histoires personnelles. Vous savez, vous lisez les blogs politiques,
ou sur les médias, les potins, etc.
Ils ont leur place, mais c'est davantage les histoires personnelles
qui m'intéressent, et c'est -- vous savez,
c'est ce que je suis.
Vous savez, vous voyez du Norman Rockwell. Les critiques d'art disent,
vous savez, Norman Rockwell ce n'est pas de l'Art.
Norman Rockwell est présent dans
des salons et des salles de bains, et ses œuvres
ne vont pas être considérées comme de l'Art.
Je pense que c'est l'une des choses les plus importantes
pour nous en tant qu'humains.
Ces choses résonnent en nous,
et si vous pensez aux blogs, vous pensez aux blogs de haut niveau,
aux peintures historiques sur les histoires bibliques,
et puis vous avez ça.
Ce sont les blogs qui m'intéressent : les gens qui racontent des histoires.
L'une des histoires
porte sur ce bébé, qui s'appelle Odin.
Son père était un blogueur.
Il était en train d'écrire sur son blog un jour,
et sa femme a donné naissance à son bébé --
à 25 semaines.
Il ne s'y attendait pas.
Un jour tout allait bien ; le lendemain c'était l'enfer.
C'est un bébé de 500 grammes.
Donc il a parlé d'Odin tous les jours.
Des photos ont été prises tous les jours, le premier jour, le deuxième.
Vous savez, le neuvième -- ils parlent de son apnée,
le 39e -- il a une pneumonie.
Ce -- son bébé est tellement petit,
et je n'ai jamais vu une
tellement --
une image si dérangeante, mais aussi si touchante.
On le lit en même temps que ça se passe,
donc le 55e jour, tout le monde lit
qu'il a des problèmes : respiratoires, cardiaques,
le rythme se ralentit, on ne sait pas ce qui va arriver.
Puis ça va mieux. Le 96e jour, il rentre à la maison.
Et on lit ce post.
Vous le lirez pas dans un article ou un magazine
mais c'est quelque chose que cette personne vit,
et cela passionne les gens.
28 commentaires. Ça ne représente pas beaucoup de lecteurs,
mais 28 personnes, ça compte.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un bébé en bonne santé,
et, vous savez, si vous lisez son blog --
c'est Snowdeal.org, le blog de son père --
il prend toujours des photos de lui, ça reste son fils
et il a, je crois, atteint le niveau normal pour son âge
parce qu'il a été tellement -- tellement bien traité à l'hôpital.
Donc, les blogs.
Bon, et alors ? Vous connaissez déjà tout ça, probablement.
On a parlé du WELL,
et on a parlé de toutes ces choses
dans notre historique en ligne.
Mais je pense que les blogs ne sont essentiellement qu'une évolution,
et que nous en sommes là aujourd'hui.
Ce sont les archives de qui vous êtes, de votre personnalité.
Vous faites une recherche sur Google : c'est quoi Mena Trott ?
Vous trouvez ces choses, vous en êtes content ou pas.
Mais vous trouvez aussi les blogs des autres,
et ce sont les archives des gens qui écrivent tous les jours --
pas forcément sur le même sujet, mais sur ce qui les intéresse.
Nous parlons du monde qui s'aplatit pour devenir ce panneau,
et je suis très optimiste.
Quand je pense aux blogs je me dis, on peut toucher tous ces gens.
Des millions, des centaines de millions, des milliards de gens.
On pénètre le territoire chinois, on veut y être,
mais tellement de gens
ne pourront pas écrire un blog.
Mais voir quelque chose comme l'ordinateur à 100 dollars est étonnant, c'est --
les logiciel de blog sont simples.
Notre société réussit grâce à son timing,
et grâce à sa persévérance, mais ce sont les choses simples --
ce n'est pas de la physique quantique.
Donc c'est incroyable quand on y réfléchit.
Donc,
les archives d'un blog sont une chose
que je trouve extrêmement importante.
Nous avons commencé par une diapo de mes Teds,
et je devais ajouter cette diapo, car je savais,
qu'à la minute où je montrerais ça, ma mère -- ma mère allait forcément voir ça,
parce qu'elle lit mon blog --
et elle allait dire, "Pourquoi il n'y a pas de photo de moi?"
C'est ma mère. Donc, j'ai tous les gens que je connais.
Mais, vous savez, c'est toute l'étendue
de la famille que je connais en
ligne directe.
J'ai déjà montré un tableau de Norman Rockwell,
j'ai grandi avec celui-là,
en le regardant constamment.
Je passais des heures à regarder les connexions.
Je me disais, 'Oh, l'enfant en haut est roux;
comme la première génération ici."
Rien que ces petites choses. Vous savez, ce n'est pas --
de la science, mais ça me suffisait
pour m'intéresser autant à notre évolution
et aux moyens de retracer notre lignée.
Cela m'a toujours influencée.
Vous savez, j'ai cette archive, ce --
ce recensement de 1910
d'un autre Grabowski -- c'est mon nom de jeune fille,
et c'est un Théodore, parce qu'il y a toujours un Théodore.
C'est tout ce que j'ai. J'ai deux ou trois
faits sur quelqu'un.
J'ai leur date de naissance, et leur âge,
ce qu'ils faisaient chez eux, s'ils parlaient anglais.
C'est tout. C'est tout ce que je sais d'eux.
C'est plutôt triste,
parce que -- je ne peux remonter qu'à cinq générations,
et c'est tout. Je ne sais même pas ce qu'il y a du côté de ma mère,
parce qu'elle vient de Cuba et que je n'ai pas grand-chose.
Rien qu'en faisant ça, j'ai passé du temps dans les archives --
c'est pourquoi -- c'est aussi pour ça que mon mari est un saint --
j'ai passé du temps dans les archives de Washington, à un bureau,
en cherchant ces choses. Maintenant c'est en ligne,
mais il a supporté tout ça.
Donc on a ces archives et,
voici mon arrière-arrière-grand-mère.
C'est la seule photo que j'ai. Penser
à ce qu'on peut faire avec nos blogs;
penser aux gens
qui sont sur ces ordinateurs à 100 dollars
à dire qui ils sont, à partager ces histoires personnelles,
c'est incroyable.
Une autre photo qui m'a beaucoup influencée,
ou une série de photos, c'est ce projet
fait par un Argentin ou sa -- et sa femme.
Il prend une photo de sa famille tous les jours
depuis -- ça fait combien depuis 76 --
20 ans, oh là là, je suis de 77 --
29 ans? 29 ans.
Il y avait une blague, à l'origine, sur un graphique que j'ai publié que,
vous voyez tous ces calculs? Je suis heureuse d'avoir pu aller jusqu'à 100,
parce que c'est ma limite en calcul.
Vous avez tous donc ces gens qui vieillissent,
et maintenant c'est eux aujourd'hui, ou l'année dernière,
et c'est très fort, de pouvoir le retracer.
J'aimerais avoir la même chose pour ma famille.
Je sais que
un jour mes enfants se demanderont --
ou mes petits-enfants, ou mes arrières petits-enfants,
si un jour j'ai des enfants --
ce que je vais --
qui j'étais, et donc je fais un geste très narcissique.
Je suis une blogueuse --
c'est une chose incroyable pour moi,
car ça saisit un moment de vie tous les jours.
Je prends une photo de moi -- je le fais depuis l'an dernier --
de moi tous les jours.
C'est la même photo ;
c'est en gros la même personne.
Seules quelques personnes le lisent. Je n'écris pas pour un public,
je le montre maintenant, mais ça me rendrait
folle si c'était vraiment publié.
Quatre personnes doivent le lire,
et ils me disent, tu n'as pas fait de mises à jour --
je vais probablement avoir des gens qui me diront que je n'ai pas mis à jour --
mais c'est une chose incroyable, parce que je peux revenir à un jour --
je peux revenir à avril 2005,
et dire, je faisais quoi ce jour-là? Je le regarde, je le sais exactement.
C'est ce rappel visuel qui est si important dans ce qu'on fait.
Je mets aussi les mauvaises photos,
parce qu'il y a de mauvaises photos.
(Rires)
Je me rappelle tout de suite : là, je suis en Allemagne --
je devais y aller pour une journée.
J'étais malade, et j'étais dans une chambre d'hôtel
et je ne voulais pas être là. Donc on le voit.
Il n'y a pas que les sourires. Maintenant j'ai évolué, donc j'ai cette tête-là.
Si vous regardez mon permis de conduire
j'ai le même air,
et c'est assez troublant
mais c'est vraiment important.
La dernière histoire
que je veux raconter est la suivante,
parce que c'est probablement celle
qui m'importe le plus dans tout ce que je fais.
Je vais sans doute avoir la gorge serrée, ça m'arrive quand j'en parle.
Donc, cette femme,
elle s'appelait Emma, c'était une blogueuse
sur notre service, TypePad. Elle testait la nouvelle version,
elle était là depuis nos débuts --
vous savez, il y avait 100 personnes --
et elle a écrit sur sa vie avec le cancer.
Elle écrivait et elle écrivait et elle écrivait,
nous nous sommes tous mis à la lire, car nous avions si peu de blogs,
nous pouvions suivre tout le monde.
Un jour, elle écrivait, et puis,
elle a disparu pendant un moment.
Sa sœur est venue sur le blog et a dit
qu'Emma était morte. Tous les employés du support technique
qui lui avaient parlé étaient très émus,
et ça a été une journée très dure dans la société.
C'était --
c'est l'un des cas où j'ai compris
à quel point le fait de bloguer affecte nos relations,
et aplatit ce genre de monde.
Que cette femme en Angleterre,
qui vit --
dans sa vie, elle parlait d'elle --
de ce qu'elle faisait.
Mais ce qui nous a vraiment marqués, c'est que
sa sœur m'a écrit pour dire...
elle a écrit sur ce blog, que
d'écrire sur son blog pendant les derniers mois de sa vie
était probablement la meilleure chose qui lui soit arrivée
et pouvoir parler aux gens, pouvoir partager ce qui se passait,
et pouvoir écrire et recevoir des commentaires.
C'était incroyable. Être en mesure de savoir
que nous avions permis ça, et qu'écrire sur un blog
était une chose qu'elle appréciait, et que
l'idée que tenir un blog n'est pas forcément effrayante,
que ce n'est pas forcément l'attaque des blogs,
que nous pouvons être des gens ouverts,
voulant aider et parler aux gens.
C'était incroyable.
Et -- donc j'ai imprimé son --
ou j'ai envoyé un PDF de son blog à sa famille,
et ils l'ont distribué à son enterrement,
et même dans son annonce de décès,
ils ont cité son blog parce qu'il était tellement important dans sa vie.
Et c'est énorme.
Donc, ceci est son héritage,
et je pense que
ma demande à chacun d'entre vous
c'est de penser aux blogs, à ce qu'ils sont,
de penser à ce que vous en avez pensé, et ensuite
d'en tenir un, parce que c'est une chose
qui va vraiment changer nos vies.
Donc, merci.
(Applaudissements)